for my whole
life milked this story about how i
[ __ ]
met you guys when i was a kid i was such
a die-hard motley crew fan
and uh it is a good [ __ ] story i mean
it's
[ __ ] about out that's when you
reached out to the call to different
hotels yeah i mean dude i was
such a [ __ ] motley crew fan right i
mean like
i had like nothing but motley crue on my
walls
you know that whole theater paint era
was was uh
i had everything like i've like the
teachers in school were
over it because every art project it was
a [ __ ] fun
it was a motley crew logo it was a
[ __ ] stuff that was just like all
right enough with the [ __ ] they were
like
wood shop making drumsticks
so yeah when they came to town i was
like dude i found out that they were
there i saw on the news they were there
before the day before the concert and
i'm like [ __ ] man that means they're
here in a hotel
so i just looked in my albums and found
out the name of their manager and just
started calling every hotel in the
yellow pages
who thinks of that like i just to me i
in my mind i'm like
dude that guy wins because who would
think of reading the
actual liner notes on a record and go oh
there's the [ __ ]
manager maybe they're under his name or
the it's the group the whole
right yeah the same person doing art
projects for school on motley crue
yeah i guess so man [ __ ] hey but
anyone who would that would
decipher that at that age like that's
that's some next level [ __ ] how old are
you
i should work for the [ __ ] cia bro
yeah yeah sure
really i was 13 at the time and uh it's
really cool that you say who would think
that because i can totally tell you
where the concept came from i was
uh like big into like little league
baseball and [ __ ] i was a super baseball
fan and
and i lived in england but every summer
i would come over to the states and
during the summer part of the
like going to the states for the summer
wherever we went my dad would
uh want to take me to a major league
baseball game and he would
plan to let's say we were in boston he
would
make sure that we were staying at the
same hotel
as the visiting team of the oh
you know so i could hang out in the
lobby and like get
autographs from uh from baseball so this
is a genetic
thing yeah totally a little bit yeah and
and when i was sitting there calling the
hotels [ __ ] for hours my mom was just
pissed because back then there was no
car waiting event it wasn't even call
waiting
she's tying up the house and she's like
she's like
she's like what [ __ ] you're tying up
the house phone for hours over here
and i'm like mom i'm calling motley crue
you know
and like my dad only ever wanted me to
show initiative to be like
passionate to [ __ ] dad was like
stoked he was like
my son this is what he's [ __ ] on fire
right now
so my dad called off my mom honey he's
calling motley crue
what city where were you living at the
time in toronto toronto
yeah in toronto that's crazy and and
dude like this was the girls girls girls
tour
so it was 1987 the concert i went to was
uh
october 25th of 1987. i did all the
calling hotels on october 24th
in the picture there you can see the the
backstage pass taped to my [ __ ]
shirt it says 10 25. that's oh okay
so he's cheating do you even remember i
mean you remember toronto
at that time that that that show i
remember meeting him for sure
really for sure yeah because yeah he's
just like oh cool
no because our tour manager well not our
tour manager our manager's brother
hit us up beforehand he's like hey man
this [ __ ]
this [ __ ] crazy kid called me in in
my room
and told me that he's [ __ ] literally
called every single hotel in toronto
looking for us and he's a massive fan
and like and uh so i'm gonna i told him
i'd bring him back to say hey to you
guys so um
so i knew about it that's great but then
when we
we met um i remember meeting him because
he was
like he is now um nothing's changed hey
dude
the [ __ ] dude
um but uh you know [ __ ] i mean that
picture of surfaces every once in a
while i see it and i still [ __ ]
i get a big smile when he's like 14
yeah for sure yeah i think you're 14. i
was 13 13 18 yeah
and and he was like 17. yeah
i know yeah dude